[Music]
special inside the issues were to take a
look now at one of America's most
distinctive and now endangered rights
the right to bear arms America is an
unusual country in a number of ways but
one way that this country stands out is
our much stronger firearms culture
America has more firearms than people
probably more civilian owned guns per
capita than any other country in the
world and unlike almost any other
country gun ownership is
constitutionally protected here why is
that
well the brand new book explores
America's long relationship with
firearms David her son he wrote that
book it's entitled first freedom a ride
through America's enduring history with
the gun and he joins us now in studio D
thanks very much for coming on thanks
for having me so the core question first
why is gun ownership constitutionally
protected in the United States well for
two reasons there's ideological reasons
it's a natural right to be able to
protect yourself your family or property
and it is the most important right
because without it obviously none of the
others exist why is it obvious what does
that mean well it's obvious because if
the people who fought at Concord and
Lexington they weren't fighting over
income inequality they were fighting
because people were coming to take their
weapons and thus they could have taken
their property or their other rights if
they had weapons so without a gun
powerful people can make you obey your
only independent work and defend
yourself oh yeah it's an authoritarian
idea to try to take the means of
protection away from the individual
right but we're told that it's actually
a way to protect the rest of us from one
another taking our guns away do you
think there's another motive at work
yeah I mean I think it's an
authoritarian motive I think how people
treat the right to self-defense tells us
a lot about how they think about the
state itself America is built obviously
on individual rights the Bill of Rights
are individual rights not elective
rights and so that goes for guns of
course as it does for free speech and
everything else so I think those people
yeah they I don't think they respect any
of the rights in the Bill of Rights
actually huh so the instinct to take
people's guns away is much bigger you're
arguing than just the desire to propel
from law-abiding citizens obviously
you know there are people who break
those laws and most of the most of the
laws that come in you know they're
they're being pushed in California and
elsewhere right now and nationally when
Obama was president is a collective
punishment for the people who already
break laws that exist they don't really
bring down gun crime in any way so the
implication of a lot of the arguments
you hear is that America has more mass
shootings because there are more guns do
we have more guns per capita than we
once had it's hard to quantify per
capita but obviously there was a huge in
the 90s there was a big dip in crime for
the next thirty twenty-five years it was
a big dip in crime but yet gun ownership
spiked at the same time so we don't you
know obviously there are many factors at
play when you're talking about that but
certainly you can't blame you know if
more people have guns there should be
more crime if that theory held so it's
not true that the more guns a community
holds the more violent crime there's no
there's no you know you look at Chicago
or Washington DC and compare it to a
town in Texas where everyone has a gun
and I mean it's pretty clear that that's
not the case so what would the K I mean
I think your book is this is pro Second
Amendment what would the case be that
you would make to someone who does not
own a gun but it sort of on the fence on
that question well I think there's the
books about the culture of guns which is
more than just an ideological question
it's embedded in the culture of America
and in the way we do commerce in the way
we we tame the West and many other ways
it was part of the DNA of our nation so
that's the first thing and I think
that's why many Americans feel about
guns the way they do which is very
unique compared to any other nation but
to change someone's mind I guess you
have to you know about guns themselves
and ownership of guns you have to
explain to them how guns help them
protect their property and their family
and their rights and that even if all
the laws they wanted were passed they
would still be violent gun violence in
fact we don't know that there would be
any less gun violence than we have today
but what we do know is that you would be
less able to protect yourself from the
state or from other individuals who want
to hurt you so really quickly that you
offer use of the history and the premise
of your book is that the history of the
gun is
embedded in the history of this country
that's widely acknowledged but often
derided as a bad thing
probably culture is the problem you
think that's true no I mean but there's
a huge revisionist effort to make it to
make it seem as if guns weren't as
important in our history as it were
because that ties into the politics of
today and you know there have been books
there are books even now coming out
where where the historians make the case
that guns weren't important in American
life that it was a collective right
never thought of as an individual right
and hopefully in my book I dispel that
notion and debunk it I think this is
really at the center of a lot of our
debates in even when it's not mentioned
and I'm grateful that you wrote this
book thanks for having me and thank you
of course